House of the Dragon had the most watched
series premiere in the history of HBO
but what does the Game of Thrones cast
think of all the hype no one has more
experience as a Targaryen than Emilia
Clarke who famously played Daenerys in
Game of Thrones Clark hasn't spoken up
in interviews or posted on social media
about season one of House of the Dragon
yet but she did offer her opinion on
photos from the set back in June 2021
calling them surreal she told The
Hollywood Reporter those pictures came
out and I was like whoa whoa I was on my
own last time I didn't know I had Pals I
could have had a bunch of friends to
hang out with but yes it's mildly
surreal to be seeing all of that again
but good luck to them is what I would
say I really mean that considering the
new series focuses so much on the
targaryens it only makes sense that
Clark would have some wisdom to impart
to the house of the Dragon cast as it
turns out she offered some guidance to
Emmy nominee Matt Smith who is taking on
the role of the ambitious and chaotic
Damon Targaryen and it's probably not
the advice you would expect beginning
tonight King's Landing will learn to
fear the color gold
in an interview with film critic Jake
Hamilton in March Smith shared the
advice given to him from the OG Queen of
Dragons get used to the wig I spoke to
kind of Amelia about that years ago
which was like oh you know I have to go
through like an hour and a half every
day of putting the wig on and it's a lot
actor Nikolai coster-waldau became a fan
favorite for his performance as Jaime
Lannister who had a roller coaster of an
arc over eight seasons of Game of
Thrones in an interview with people at
the 2022 Cannes Film Festival in May the
Danish actor opened up about his
thoughts on the impending debut of House
of the Dragon he told people I've seen
the trailer it seems very familiar
Miguel sapochnik who's the showrunner
directed some of the big episodes in
Game of Thrones so I have a feeling it's
going to be quite surreal to watch it
House of the Dragon has an incredible
cast I hope they'll have all the success
Jon Snow actor kit Harrington met his
wife Rose Leslie on the set of Game of
Thrones turning their steamy on-screen
romance into real-life happiness so it
makes sense that Harrington plans on
watching House of the Dragon but says it
may be a little painful to watch in an
interview with Insider in October 2021
Harrington admitted that the prospect of
a new show in the world of Westeros
makes him emotional especially since his
experiences on Game of Thrones are still
so recent he told the outlet I think to
see people get into outfits and costumes
that resemble what we wore for all those
years and it has the same music and
style and tone but not be in it there's
going to be a rawness there Arya Stark
actor Maisie Williams is close friends
with Olivia Cook who plays Alison
Hightower in House of the Dragon she
told Variety in May that she will
definitely be watching the show adding I
want to be as supportive as possible to
Olivia as an actress but also I'm just
really curious I'm kind of looking
forward to watching Game of Thrones even
though it's not Game of Thrones and
experiencing it as a person that's not
on it John Bradley who played Samwell
tarly is also excited for the new series
and being able to enjoy it as a viewer
not an actor Bradley told Yahoo news in
May I'm very very excited to watch it
and not be worried that my scene's next
Peter Dinklage echoed the sentiment to
The Independent in January the Tyrion
Lannister actor told the outlet I am
excited to watch House of the Dragon
purely as a viewer not knowing what will
happen next Gwendolyn Christy who played
Brienne of Tarth was asked by extra in
July about House of the dragon and said
she was eager for fans to see it saying
I think it will be great for people to
see what feels like a continuation of
the Game of Thrones story it was so
beloved and still is now and um I will
never stop loving Brienne of Tarth
[Music]